a funny thing is happening the dollar
has been surging massively it's up 24
percent since June go back even further
and you can see it now at its highest
level in 12 years that's quite the
turnaround from just a few years ago
when everyone was down on the dog in
2007 the model of Giselle insisted that
she get paid in Euros and JZ flag euros
in the video and then the immediate
aftermath of the financial crisis we
were told everything was going wrong for
the dollar the Fed was printing money
like crazy shrinking the dollars value
the gigantic US budget deficits were
supposedly eroding confidence in the
dollar plus other countries seem to have
growth prospects that made them much
more appealing to investors so what
happened the US recovery is now the envy
of the world and it looks like the Fed
is ready to hike interest rates before
other major central banks US government
deficits have shrunk massively and the
collapse of oil prices means our import
bill is disappearing while Japan and
Europe limp along with fresh easing
programs designed to give their
economies of boost the US dollars once
again King